showing off military force near the
border with ukraine these war games held
by russia and belarus have not only
spooked the west but also many
belarusians
president alexander lukashenko's remarks
when visiting one of the training
grounds added to the concerns
if necessary if such stupid and mindless
steps are taken by our rivals and
opponents we will not only deploy
nuclear weapons but super nuclear ones
to protect our country but if there are
no threats we don't need nuclear weapons
for 100 years
belarus will hold a referendum next week
to amend the country's constitution not
only letting lukashenka stay in power
but also allowing nuclear weapons from
russia to be based in the country
lukashenka has been isolated by the west
after a violent crackdown on protesters
in the past year and a half he turned to
putin for help in return russia is
increasingly using belarus on the border
with nato as a military training ground
troops have arrived here from as far as
10 000 kilometers away the far east of
russia while russia has now announced
that it's withdrawing its troops back to
the south and the west of the country
away from belarus many are wondering
what will happen to the other russian
forces here in pinsk just 30 kilometers
from the border belarusians and
ukrainians have lived together for
generations they are worried about being
dragged into a possible war
i personally think it's a dangerous
president i don't like that so many
russians come to belarus the situation
around ukraine is very tense and we are
all deeply worried ukrainian people are
very close to us our towns have very
good relations with ukrainians my heart
aches for ukraine also we're afraid the
occupation has been happening silently
and we don't like it because we fear
that russian troops may stay here
and their presence is very much felt
driving around the south of belarus
satellite images appear to show that
instead of withdrawing more troops are
being sent to the region the trails are
scheduled to end on february 20. only
then it will become clear if soldiers
will return to their bases as moscow has
promised step faster al jazeera in
luninettes belarus